oh yeah via can hear me yeah we were
just attacked listen your friend from my
hotels awake you're right about him
being immune to this thing if it wasn't
for him we wouldn't have made it maybe
now we can hold out until help her eyes
side you're my wife get out of there and
I can help you I can arrange for
transportation by air by sea but first
you need to get here to me husa stay
with an injured ma they're crazy with
fear tell me where you are where are you
you there mate hello hello ok help Danny
just not okay we lose its cool yeah just
touching get with you for one yeah yeah
and how do I level of extras no thanks
to you oh yeah I like that I like that
name is John Sinha my head lifeguard
voice on the radio tell me you were in
trouble at the hotel so you were
resistant to whatever this is I didn't
believe it family I saw the bite marks
you got no symptoms but love bites are
they who you are or how you know that
going on the radio but he's our only
connection with the other solo sexo keep
losing the bloody signal we have a
monsoon coming so here's the thing we
need to move everybody to the main
lifeguard station there's an ambulance
there and more equipment in a stronger
radio with an antenna hate to ask but we
can't do this without you you help me
yeah sure sure sure all right good first
off we need an access card to get past
the security gate mine's in my room with
all the commotion I forgot to take it
with it's an Anglo liven up by the pools
take a weapon and watch yourself in may
be immune that out mean you can't die
okay hello I grant haha [ __ ] I should
have never listened a cinema why the
hell did I stay here with cinema I
should have listened to Maggie and left
with James and the others they probably
found a way off the island by now maybe
there's still time to find Steven them
here if you're out there and you see
Maggie letters could you let me know
where they are yeah sure sure I'll do
what I can ah thanks i'll be here who's
I mean you know what the hell else am I
gonna go okay but had do I level up does
anyone know that aina haina shift enter
okay how the heck oh let me just find
out what the controls are
um k binding its I oh it's you it's you
oh here you go okay
ok
this is good this is good Oh inventory
and using this next / / mod okay okay
all right let's do this mm-hmm sure
I thought I was doing like quest how it
is your immunity
how do you
okay Rick security guard from bungalow
11 and find Maggie okay how do I find
out what bungalow there oh look Chris
Marker okay
that's just gone you know my usual way
and not China to mess with anybody or
ruffle any feathers and now just a
smoother you know not a feather rather
were and I don't like the ruffle shelf
oh oh oh great
Jesus this is getting very violent I
have to say okay getting hurt alright i
guess i was under maybe there's
something we can use
just got half the parish yes sir okay I
don't have anything this good Jeff good
good i like how that played out i think
i need Jesus can I take on these things
to fight with a something to [ __ ]
fight with
okay o.o cut cake didn't okay yes food
gut gut Lucia shake still I know if it
does I like killing myself here and I
forget you know I think for the dev sir
I love surprises My Fair surprises a
monetary surprise it is it like I'm not
gonna be like sicker I just drink
people's energy drinks bloody hell okay
[ __ ] my own [ __ ] brother Jesus Christ
what else could I do let him kill me and
this guy's identical with the [ __ ] you
want from me I had no choice
at what it tells
take that / have my floaty knife see
your push-ups
this is Roger Howard on a special
assignment on the island of Vanua I'm
investigating illegal logging and clear
cutting that's not only damaging the
ecosystem here but costing the people of
van no aid billions I've been told that
my life might be in danger and staying
behind this illegal activity will stop
at nothing to protect their criminal
ever I go so that if something were to
happen to me the gang true that would
still be told I'm leaving now to lead
with an informant who I believe could
rip the lid on this investigation
do I want to find out over that now
he's dead
Oh
it's bloody beautiful isn't it oh yeah
yeah it is i sorry I early notice those
things a bit about the pop-ups yeah I'm
not seeing Maggie then I think she died
thank you did you did it all right
thanks to you my mind all just like it
uh yeah man he's dead Maggie was right
no thanks to you okay ready to go out
there again I'll need you to find a
lifeguard station and save it safe you
do that for me sure sure that's hard
sure thing it's like the beach it's the
shortest why come as soon as we know
it's safe it should be a working radio
inside signals when it's clear we'll
follow you that girl is very tough one
here except someone join me yeah upgrade
available now no
I said it's a beautiful day though you
can't can't say it's not and I like my
paddles fire thank you there's that
turtle now I chose this I get good i
like his bracelet tho yeah this [ __ ] oh
Jesus
thank ya thank ya see I'm living out of
energy drinks here I thank you and like
pipe died so quickly can't hurt to look
okay I got the baseball bat I'm good I'm
good I packed them golden you know first
eat a kick okay I don't know that how's
that
Oh sir oh yeah good yeah Ike that yeah
yes sir ok this one Jesus Christ if you
had me cold p do Dr Vance and you want
to come with me I'm gathering any
supplies I can find in the water sports
right at ER scope let's find something
that'll come in handy ok sorry ready
let's do this uh uh hello ma'am bloody
hell
uh-huh
carletti ah disgusting oh that right nah
yeah God all right I got a job out of
this
yeah but that k Tamara Oh was that last
it is a kind of the beach I was like
[ __ ] suffering it just sued us a show
like never play with other players you
know because it looks like breathe too
much an area and just make too much
noise okay the ore is right here again
we see a guy were there was there Harris
create a lot of zombies love
yeah I like that I like that oh I like
that a lot you need help sir oh Jesus
Christ if you hadn't come over if you
want to come with that death and
entering any supplies I can find at the
water sports rental kiosk maybe you'll
find something that'll come in here that
each level of level up I'm gonna choose
this one
oh you gotta pay for that Jesus
that sure we'll take whatever you want
Hey look at in here okay I guess I'll up
read this right I don't know you and how
that
I don't even know i just did i'll just
get all this stuff and make some really
good one I probably get something you
know I have to get some rest I'm sure
you do okay so sorry I'm already gone
didn't go catch that all right
okay okay I'd like to take the money
before they fall this knife is almost
dead but if I get
what's in here stay the hell down see
that
I don't anything go that way it doesn't
look like a safe place the safe haven
you know like yes a lot of combos a lot
of combos in this game
oh wow
come on rabbit bloody animals a few be
honest I just said huh I pretty proud of
myself
hi I'm here with the card reader
ok
smack that booty
is that
oh right
there is a here for
alright
that blew up good
oh yeah that
ok
oh Jesus
what the heck
and they gonna be pleasantly surprised
when they land in here
Jesus
uh honey like a weapon
anyone up here
oh Jesus
[ __ ] out good yeah pseudo handle a
situation a hand a lot maybe there's
something we can use
I'm here for the radio here's the radio
oh I gotta kill all these guys first
Jesus I can't initialized one i
neutralize phone
yes sir quick way to use that
okay okay
yeah they are
hey okay all right just continually
searching looking for my necks paying
job you know its life of an actor okay
all right thank ya thank ya thank ya and
pick yeah I can't thank ya and I think
how to thank you ok this is get this is
good
ah lucky right now they had a car that's
really good my beautiful pays us
good on ya let's see how he got ya let's
see how it we got here okay
oh that's what i really need Jesus good
job mate I'm safe now thanks to you or
make it a long way out food help them
come soon even if to town means like
maybe you can see if anybody needs help
not get cat all right well we're gonna
add their guys are gonna out there I
hope y'all enjoy that I did is a little
crazy but uh Scotty else has it's got
chicken and yes